hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in a work entitled the ethics of
ambiguity we can expect that this
notion or concept or term ambiguity
is going to play a really central role
in the work and indeed it does now
ambiguity was around for a very long
time before debevoir started talking
about it
other people invoke ambiguity as well
in philosophy and even in the
existentialist
movement so we want to try to provide
a preliminary clarification of the term
before we jump
in and this is particularly important
because she is using it
in a way that's a little bit different
than what you might find if you go to
a dictionary definition particularly if
your dictionary doesn't have a wide
range of definitions because ambiguity
originally is viewed as something that
is is primarily
about language and meaning
so it's about expressions
that can be interpreted in multiple ways
they have
more than one sense a prime example of
this sometimes we call this
equivocation right but ambiguity would
be
not exactly the same thing as
equivocation but could include it
if we use the word seal that can mean
the animal
it can mean the action of sealing
something it can mean
the stamp that we use to impress on wax
and it can mean a british pop singer
among other things we might come up with
other terms
as well so ambiguity can happen at the
level of single terms it can happen
at the level of entire sentences we can
talk about
even you know whole chapters of a work
being
ambiguous particularly if you're not
sure precisely what they're referring to
hegel's phenomenology
is a prime example because he so rarely
names names so you're reading through
a dialectic and you're like what is this
actually referring to i guess it could
be this
or it could be this think for example
about the famous master slave dialectic
that has been used like the proverbial
wax nose that can be bent in so many
different ways to signify
so many different things including by de
bevoir herself right so there's
there's a lot of ambiguity in language
but we can also talk about
ambiguity within situations how do you
read a situation can it be interpreted
in more than one way and you know you
can think about all the different
uh dodges that people have when they get
caught
oh i wasn't stealing i was putting the
money back
right you just happened to have caught
me as i was getting it out to
to you know brush off some dust off of
the dollar bills or something like that
oh there's more than one reading of the
situation obviously one of them is
probably
false but it is ambiguous right actions
what is a person doing this is a
fundamental problem in ethics
you know when a manual con invokes
the maxims of your action you have to be
able to say what the maxim is and the
same
action could be described in in
different ways
thomas aquinas in the middle ages talked
about the need to zero
in on the moral species of the action
and a similar sort of thing
we use the term proper description in
the 20th century in analytic philosophy
to talk about that motivations a lot of
different ways we can interpret
the way in which a person talks about
themselves
what they value you know it's not it's
not always so straightforward and simple
and then we can also talk about our
human condition
itself is that perhaps ambiguous or is
it you know
straightforward and so when something is
ambiguous we have the capacity for
multiple interpretations and those
interpretations can be
very crude uh not well thought out they
can be
very refined very nuanced take
other interpretations into account and
say why they're bad interpretations
but according to de bouvoir ambiguity
is something that we we cannot get rid
of and as a matter of fact
she is going to criticize other
philosophers
for ignoring the ambiguity
of our situation she talks about her
human condition
as involving tragic ambiguity so here's
a good place to go
to the text what is this tragic
ambiguity well in her first
paragraph she describes some of the
we could call the modes or high notes of
this
she says um rational animal
thinking read the human beings escape
from their natural condition
without however freeing themselves from
it we are part of this world
of which we are a consciousness so we're
something within the world
but we're also something that discloses
that
understands the world we assert
ourselves as a pure
internality against which no external
power can take hold you know when we
engage
in willing and choice in deciding for
ourselves
but we also experience ourselves as a
thing
crushed by the dark weight of other
things so
we have the paradox or the problem of
you know freedom and and determinism
uh at every moment he the person can
grasp the non-temporal truth of their
existence
but between the past which no longer is
in the future which is not yet
this moment when we exist is nothing
this privilege which we alone possess of
being a sovereign
and unique subject among a universe of
objects
is what we share with all of our fellow
human beings
in turn an object for others we are
nothing more than an individual
in the collectivity on which we depend
so these are you know some prime aspects
of our
human condition they're not reducible
just to one type of
ambiguity this situation is ambiguous in
in many ways we could look at a person's
action and say
is that genuinely a free action or are
they
being pushed by forces beyond their
control or
below their level of consciousness or by
the way we've
nudged them in setting up the situation
perhaps one perhaps the other perhaps
both
you know there's there's all these
aspects to the human
condition which are you know capable of
of
multiple interpretations multiple ways
of grasping them multiple ways of
looking at them this is part of what
makes ethics possible in the first place
this ambiguity
according to devoir so she criticizes
philosophers
for uh having ignored or having
tried to downplay this ambiguity in
favor of something else they they didn't
just say oh
ambiguity get rid of it you know oh it's
bad or something like that
no they wanted to propose something else
in its place
so you know she says as long as there
have been men
and they have lived they felt this
tragic ambiguity of their condition but
as long as there have been philosophers
and they have thought most of them have
tried to mask it
they've striven to reduce mind to matter
or to reabsorb matter into mind we have
materialism and idealism there right
or to merge them within a single
substance a kind of monism
and these are all reductive or
there is a dualism those who have
accepted the dualism have established a
hierarchy
between body and soul which permits of
considering as
negligible the part of the self which
cannot be
saved they've denied death either by
integrating it with life or promising to
man
immortality or they've denied life
considering it is a veil of illusion
beneath which is hidden the truth of
nirvana now of course she's getting
nirvana a bit wrong there from a
buddhist perspective
but you understand what she's what she's
after there a lot of philosophers
responses
have been rather reductive and why
why be reductive because they don't like
the ambiguity that's there and and it's
difficult to deal with and it means that
everything that you've written is never
quite finished
so there's a impulse to get rid of it
she also criticizes those who
attempt to reconcile all of this
together she talks about hegel
as a prime example right she says
before that though she says it's been a
matter of eliminating ambiguity by
making oneself by working upon oneself
by taking a stance on what one is
pure inwardness or pure externality by
escaping from the sensible world
or being engulfed in it by yielding to
eternity or enclosing oneself in the
pure moment so
every one of these we could call them
speculative
choices also has a practical upshot what
we do
as human beings philosophy is philosophy
as a way of life now what else
she says hegel with more ingenuity tried
to reject none of the aspects
of the human condition and to reconcile
them
all according to his system the moment
is preserved in the development of time
nature asserts itself in the face of
spirit which denies it while assuming it
the individual is again found in the
collectivity with when
within which he is lost and each
person's death is fulfilled by being
canceled out until she uses capitals
life of mankind one can repose in a
marvelous optimism
and you know she talks about this and
this could be an emblem for so many
other viewpoints attempting to have like
the the system that reconciles
everything that makes sense out of
everything
there are many different varieties of
this
devoir doesn't want to go that route and
she thinks that existentialism as a
movement
is a refusal of that route and a
criticism of that route
she says that we should look the truth
in the face what is the truth the truth
of our
tragic ambiguity of the human condition
that we're actually caught in and she
says that we should
assume our fundamental ambiguity and she
then she says it's in the knowledge of
the genuine conditions of our life that
we must draw our strength to live
and our reason for acting so it's not
just about
you know managing to find something
that'll work for us
and continuing on and then stopping
thinking after that there's a continual
process where we have to
reinterpret ambiguity hereby becomes you
could say productive and in a certain
sense guiding
and she talks about existentialism as
being from the start from
kierkegaard onward a philosophy
of existentialism she also you know says
well other
people say that it's a philosophy of the
absurd a philosophy of despair
she's going to contest that later on in
the work particularly in the section
towards the end
where she says that ambiguity is not the
same thing as absurdity
and she's she's uh prioritizing
ambiguity
and so we can ask about existentialism
and notice that there's an
ambiguity here as well well is it a
philosophy of the absurd
and despair or is it a philosophy of
ambiguity
of hope perhaps or at least a commitment
and freedom
it's it's up to the existentialists to
interpret to
decide and not all existentialists will
necessarily go the same way
de bevoir is trying to provide a reason
for why
to go her way with this
and she begins by talking about sartre
her you know lifelong companion
and collaborator now interestingly this
book
is by many viewed as
accomplishing what jean-paul sark was
unable to pull off and she does in fact
criticize being in nothingness a little
bit here
saying that it's true that in being and
nothingness
sartre insisted on the abortive aspect
of the human adventure it's only in the
last pages he
opens up the perspective for ethics now
opens up the perspective for ethics is
not the same thing as provides an ethics
right which is what she in fact is
attempting to do here
in this work so she is completing
something that starts in
in sart's philosophy you could really
say in in their philosophy right
so she goes on and she she talks about
here we go um sartan being in
nothingness fundamentally defined man
that being whose being is not to be that
subjectivity which realizes itself
only as a presence in the world that
engaged
freedom that surging of the for itself
which is immediately given for others
right so that already includes a lot of
ambiguity how do you what do you
make of freedom what do you make of this
surge this presence into the world what
do you make of the fact that others can
interpret you
as well that's part of the dynamic
that's worked out in
sart's uh uh work and and she goes on
and and talks about here we go
this failure described in being in
nothingness
right the failure to attain the
god-like status or object-like status
of being in itself of having attained
a completely stable not just identity
but
read on the world this failure she says
is definitive but it is also ambiguous
itself the failure is
ambiguous the failure involves ambiguity
how do you interpret it what do you make
of it she says being
a man sartre tells us is a being who
makes himself a lack of being in order
that there
might be being and so what does that
mean that's that's a
rather ambiguous phrase right there and
she tells us that this has
metaphysical and i use the word moral
here just because i'm thinking of the
you know nice way in which these are
always tied together in french things
there's the reviewed metaphysical morale
which was one of the flagship philosophy
journals we could say ethical as well
um there's there's there's some
dimensions to human being
that are automatically metaphysical and
moral and sart was exploring these
in being in nothingness intentionality
having some sort of direction
towards goals but goals that are not
fixed once and for
all but goals that we in some respect
once we become conscious
of ourselves choose whether to keep as
goals or whether to
move away from as goals
what this desire to disclose being
right she goes on and says
here we go sartre tells us
that man makes himself this lack of
being
in order that there might be be being
the term in order that clearly indicates
intentionality it's not in vain that
that human beings nullify being
thanks to the human being being is
disclosed
and humans desire this disclosure
there's an original type of attachment
to being which is not the relationship
wanting to be myself but rather wanting
to
disclose being and she says here
there is not failure but rather success
but it's it's a success that we don't
dominate we don't control
in revealing to myself as she says the
landscape or in my case
revealing to myself this chalkboard
filled with notes on something i'm going
to talk about
but might have forgotten about at this
point i'm struggling to make sense of it
while i pick up the book
and read it i am reinterpreting the
situation
and i am taking stances existential
stances
in a rather minor way by by doing so
it's not affecting the totality of my
life
unless i'm investing you know my status
as an intellectual at every single point
or something like that
and there's a few other things that need
to be pointed out here that are very
uh interesting and important for
understanding
the scope of ambiguity she talks about
uh something that hegel uh brings up
and and hegel is not the only
philosopher
who does this this idea that um
you know if everything was solved if
everything was
clear there really would be no scope for
for ethics
ethics not understood as just like a set
of rules or
principles by which we then machine like
operate and and solve things
ethics understood is a distinctively
human
activity which involves us in in making
choices
and not just making choices at a low
level but also
prioritizing deciding do i think that
the categorical imperative that can't
put forward
is really how i should guide my life i
know what will be the case
if i choose the categorical imperative
provided i'm actually applying it
properly and not being sloppy
or making exceptions for myself but i
don't
yet know whether i should
follow it or maybe i think i know
because my parents were
strict conscience and brought me up in
that way and
you weren't even you know explicit
conscience just you know
focused on on doing your duty and talked
about universalization and not using
people
so when i read conte i was like this is
perfect
that from an existentialist perspective
is still a choice
there's there's still a fundamental
ambiguity there
involving our freedom involving our
capacity to
select more than one thing and then zero
in on one of them to the exclusion of
the others
that is part of the ambiguity so the
ethical exists for humans who are
posed with situations with problems
usually problems that are messy usually
problems where we're already steering to
one side
but we're not sure about the things
we've left behind
so this is very important as well if we
try to get rid of all the ambiguity we
effectively rule out the ethical
the last thing that i want to bring up
is her
refusal of a certain a priori
and this is uh an important
uh point in in the work
where she's bringing in one of the key
themes which is namely
that of the freedom of others and
whether i
am going to be irrevocably opposed to
the freedom of others
and they to mine or whether it's
possible for these to be brought
together so she says
an ethics of ambiguity will be one which
will refuse to deny
a priori that separate existence can
at the same time be bound to each other
that their individual freedoms
can forge laws valid for all now when
you look at that sentence
it's it's rather confusing the way it's
framed what she's saying
is that many people do take it as an a
priori as something that we just have to
accept as given we can't think otherwise
that um separate existence
can at the same time be bound to each
other this is this is what a priori
people are denying
right there can't be any sort of
solidarity there can't be any
way in which we can harmonize our
freedoms that their individual freedoms
can forge laws valid for all how can you
go from the individual to
to the uh collective as she's calling it
to
to you know the universal of human kind
and she's saying
and she's not saying an ethics of
ambiguity is asserting this
she's saying it's refusing to deny what
is the difference between those
it could be that it is the case that you
really you can't bring this off
we don't know until we try and we
discover the truth you might say in a
pragmatic way
by trying and then reflecting on what
our action
or its failure has brought about and
that
is is integral to this this work and
that too
is part of what she's meaning by
ambiguity so we're going way beyond
ambiguity is a function of language of
you know
meaning of phrases to thinking about
things that are much closer
to who we are as moral and you might say
metaphysical beings and so
existentialism
is going to be a philosophy that takes
this
this issue this this directive seriously
you